today on the matt walsh show the media
is breathlessly reporting that trump
refused to condemn
white supremacists in last night's
debate it's a lie
he did condemn them he's already
condemned them he's condemned them many
times meanwhile joe biden
and the rest of the democrats have
actually never condemned the violent
extremists
in their midst like blm and antifa
that's the real outrage considering that
these groups are currently burning down
our cities
we'll talk about that also five
headlines including an unintentionally
hilarious
fact check on a babylon bee article you
have to hear this one to
really believe it and in our daily
cancellation we'll cancel the atlantic
for trying to make a scandal out of the
fact that trump
allegedly makes fun of televangelists in
private
who doesn't all of that on the way first
a word from
duke cannon uh like a lot of you you
know i've tried
different body washes from the store and
i'm always disappointed in them you know
they're expensive they often smell too
fruity for my taste
and they just they don't get the job
done but that's why i use duke cannon's
big ass brick of soap what else needs to
be said about it i mean it's it's a big
ass brick of soap it's exactly what it
claims to be
very simple to the point you know that's
what you want as a man now this is part
of their frontier 40 collection and all
of these products have scents that
will take you straight into the rugged
untouched wilderness each of the four
cents in the frontier 40
campfire fresh cut pine leaf leather and
midnight swim
come in a 10-ounce brick that will leave
you smelling like the best elements
mother nature has to offer and of course
you know i'm also going to be using
buchanan's beard products uh it's it's
true scientifically that beards are
bulletproof
indestructible they grant you
immortality all that's true but that
doesn't mean you
you don't take care of them that doesn't
mean that you don't need to groom them
that's why i use a duke cannon beard oil
beard balm beard soap beard wash
yes all of them every day you got a
problem with that
but listen even if you don't have a
beard as disgraceful as that is
you should still try the frontier 40 um
though it may be tempting to you know
get off the grid let's be honest
we may not have the time instead satisfy
your wanderlust
right from the shower with the nature
inspired sense of
of the four big ass bricks of soap in
the frontier 40 visit dukecanon.com use
promo code walsh
10 for 10 off your next order free
shipping with orders over 20
a selection of duke cannas products are
also available at your local
target so go pick those up now all right
now there are many negative um
but honest headlines you could write
about tuesday night's semi-coherent
shouting match between donald trump and
joe biden and joe biden's
de facto spokesman chris wallace but
the media has settled on a headline
ripped straight from their own fever
dreams
npr says from the debate stage trump
declines to denounce white supremacy
trump refuses to denounce white
supremacy in chaotic debate according to
the new york times
uh trump doesn't denounce white
supremacists and militias during debate
abc news insists politico puts it this
way
trump's jarring white supremacist moment
launches an
online furor even fox and friends has
gotten in on the action uh listen to
this
if you're going to say that president
trump was rude there was only one person
who
called the other one a clown a racist
uh the worst president ever and told to
shut up
and that was joe biden on donald trump
but donald trump ruled the biggest layup
in the history of debates
by saying not condemning white
supremacists i don't know if he didn't
hear it but he's got to clarify that
right away
that's like are you against evil why the
president didn't just
knocked out of the park i'm not sure but
none of this is actually true
one need only watch the relevant clip
from the debate to see that president
trump
did indeed denounce white supremacists
here it is
listen for yourself you have repeatedly
criticized
the vice president for not specifically
calling out antifa
and other left-wing extremist groups but
are you willing
tonight to condemn white supremacists
and militia groups
and to say that they need to stand down
and not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland
i would say almost everything i see is
from the left wing
not from the right what are you what are
you doing what are you saying i'm i'm
willing to do anything i want to see
peace sir say it do it say it
do you want to call him what do you want
to call him give me your name give me a
white surprise
and write presents stand back and stand
by
okay let's go through the transcript
wallace you have repeatedly criticized
the vice president for not specifically
calling out antifa and other left-wing
extremist groups but are you willing
tonight to condemn
white supremacists and militia groups
and to say that they need to stand down
and not add to the violence in a number
of these cities as we've seen in kenosha
and we've seen in portland
trump sure i'm willing to do that
biden then do it wallace go ahead sir
trump i would say i would say almost
everything i see is from the left wing
not from the right
wallace so what are you saying trump i'm
willing to do anything i want
i want to see peace wallace then do it
sir biden
say it do it say it trump
do you want do you want to call them
what do you want to call them give me a
name
give me a name go ahead who would you
like me to condemn
wallace white supremacists and
right-wing militias biden proud boys
trump uh proud boys stand back and stand
by
okay now so you've heard it i read the
transcript to you
there it is i may not be the smartest
man okay but it seems to me that
when somebody asks are you willing to
condemn white supremacists
and you respond sure as in yes
i condemn them you have condemned them
right there the stand back and stand by
comment was weirdly phrased but this is
trump we're talking about first of all
and also
it should be obvious to any any honest
person attempting to parse
trump's words that he meant stand down
which is the phrase that wallace used
unfortunately there aren't very many
honest people in the media so instead
they're pretending to believe that trump
was rallying his white supremacist
militia horde and telling them to stand
by for the coming invasion
but this is all beside the point
the problem is the question itself not
the answer
being asked to condemn white
supremacists is like being asked to
condemn that you're a pedophile
the point of the question is to create
the association
in the audience's mind by condemning or
denying in that context
you're implicitly legitimizing the
premise
that there is some sort of potential
connection between you
and the evil thing now it's claimed that
trump
must condemn white supremacy because as
biden has charged in the past
trump has never once done so
that's flat out untrue okay going back
to the infamous
charlottesville rally in 2017 trump said
that he quote
condemns in the strongest possible terms
this egregious display
of hatred bigotry and violence on many
sides
two days later he said in a statement we
condemn in the strongest possible terms
this egregious display of hatred bigotry
and violence
it has no place in america and as i have
said many times before no matter the
color of our skin we all live under the
same laws we all salute the
same great flag we are all made by the
same almighty god we must love each
other
show affection for each other and unite
together in condemnation of hatred
bigotry and violence
we must rediscover the bonds of love and
loyalty that bring us together
as americans racism is is evil
and those who cause violence in the name
in its name are
criminals and thugs including the kkk
neo-nazis white supremacists and other
hate groups that are repugnant to
everything we hold there as americans
the next day in a press conference we're
not done yet
trump again emphasized that neo-nazis
and white nationalists
should be condemned totally condemned
totally that's three condemnations in
the span of four days how many times
does trump need to explain that nazis
are bad
does he have to deliver an address from
the rose garden every morning to remind
us that
he still doesn't like racists and nazis
hey by the way guys
i'm still opposed to nazis just letting
you know okay have a great thursday
meanwhile nazis and white supremacists
are not the ones
who have been rampaging in our streets
for months on end
they are not the ones who've looted and
burned and killed and caused billions of
dollars of property damage this summer
alone
as trump correctly pointed out left-wing
extremist groups are the real threat we
face
and democrats including joe biden have
not only refused to condemn these
dangerous forces but have explicitly
promoted them and supported them biden
last night came
valiantly to antifa's defense saying
they are an idea
not an organization listen i'll tell you
what
somebody's got to do something about
antifa and the left because this is not
a right-wing problem
this is a lefty director this is a
left-wing
white supremacist antifa is an idea not
an organization you've got it
not militia that's what his tonight fbi
his fbi director said no no no we're
we're done sir and if democrats are
reluctant to condemn antifa
as trump as biden clearly was there we
can be sure that they will never
and have never whispered a single word
of criticism however mild
towards black lives matter a radical
racist marxist
extremist group which seeks to destroy
the nuclear family get rid of the police
among other stated goals and whose
leaders
openly encourage looting and violence no
group in recent history has damaged this
country
physically and in every other sense to
the same degree as blm
three years after the fact you know the
media still hasn't gotten over trump's
very fine people phrasing which they are
willfully misinterpreting
for months though democrats have been
telling us that there are very fine
people among the rioters looters and
murderers in the blm antifa mob
indeed listening to them tell it they're
all fine people fighting for truth and
justice by burning down their local
convenience store and beating
random pedestrians half to death they
are the ones who should be issuing
condemnations
but they will never be forced to condemn
nor asked why they are not condemning
that's the advantage of having nearly
all of the mainstream media
on your side which we saw again
starkly illustrated last night let's get
to our five headlines
[Music]
you know i've been telling you about dot
rockauto.com for a long time that's
because i'm trying to save you money
save you money on time well i'm not i
mean they are i guess i can't really
take credit for it but
there's just no reason to go to the auto
body store
um and spend hours on that
uh uh you know task that errand when you
consider you got to get in the car
drive there walk around the store do all
that no reason to do it when you got
rockauto.com
um it's it's so much easier than walking
into a store
so much easier than going to a mechanic
also going to be a lot cheaper
just go to rockauto.com they always have
the lowest prices possible
they're not going to change the prices
they're not going to you know figure out
how much they think they can
milk you for and then and then go for
that no um they're gonna give you the
lowest prices they possibly can
rockauto.com
look they're a family business honest
business they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com right now to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are reliably low
uh they're the same for professionals
same for do-it-yourselfers
and there's just no reason to spend
twice as much for the same parts twice
as much for the same parts or
twice as much for not even the part
you're really looking for
the rockauto.com catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate
you can quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and uh
choose the brands specifications prices
that are right for you
and uh you know what i like about the
website is very very easily organized so
you don't need to be
an expert to find your way around and
find what you're looking for go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck
wright walsh in there how did you hear
about us box so that they know that we
sent you
all right um now camila harris this week
went to
pay her respects to ruth bader ginsburg
and afterwards decided to solemnly and
very respectfully
use ginsburg's death for political gain
as is the tradition in washington very
very very sacred tradition listen to
this
we are about to undertake the task of
finding her replacement
on the united states supreme court
of course it's hard to say those words
in truth ruth bader ginsburg
cannot be replaced she was an original
a one-of-a-kind she combined a
steel spine with an ability to extend an
open hand never a closed
fist she demonstrated you could both
hold firm to your principles
and still hear those with whom you
disagree
that is a lesson that should be ringing
in our
ears but it looks like this president
and his party
are not interested in hearing any of the
lessons
from justice ginsburg already the
president and his party have chosen to
ignore
justice ginsburg's final wish to hold
off the nomination
to replace her until after the next
president
is chosen a wish by the way
shared by the american people this
talking point i mean my god it is so
stupid it's beyond the bounds of normal
stupid
uh and they're still going with it
they're they're gonna run this thing
they're gonna run with it
this final wish gambit all the way
through uh there is no final wish clause
of the constitution i don't know how
many times we have to explain this
the supreme court is not the make-a-wish
foundation final wishes are
constitutionally irrelevant um so
this this could it could not be less
relevant than it is
the supreme court seats are not
bequeathed to an
heir you can't leave them in your will
right so it's not going to be
uh yeah grandma left you the jewelry box
and
oh look at that a supreme court seat
congratulations
that's not how this works uh so just
what a monumentally stupid thing
good lord okay speaking of monumentally
stupid things number two this is a this
this is real
amazingly usa today ran a fact check on
a babylon b
article the babylonian article which
said that the ninth circuit court of
appeals overturned the death of supreme
court justice ruth bader ginsburg
now they over overturned her death
usa today did some research on this ran
down some leads hit the pavement you
know
and they concluded it's probably
probably not true
so this is the usa today article says
the claim the ninth circuit court of
appeals overturned the death of supreme
court justice ruth bader ginsburg
the headline of an article published by
satire website the babylon b is a nod to
the contentious history between the
trump administration the u.s
court of appeals the babylon b is the
world's best satire site according to
its website supreme court justice
ginsburg who died of pancreatic cancer
september 18th is actually alive the
article suggests because the ninth
circuit
overturned her death in a close decision
the judges on the court have ruled rbg's
death unconstitutional and
will block trump from nominating a
replacement the article says
ninth circuit judge kim mclean wardlaw
was credited with issuing the ruling on
the basis that ginsburg death was an
affront to the constitution
and then it uh goes on from there
and it finally gets to the verdict there
is no record of any ward law opinion on
ginsburg's death on the website of the
ninth circuit
but she they actually looked it up on
the website they looked this up on the
website to see if this really happened
but she participated in a panel
discussion friday about ginsburg's life
produced by the ucla law school
uh there was no mention of reviving
ginsburg during the discussion
okay now if i wanted to try really hard
to defend usa today here
i'm not sure why i would want to do that
but if i did i might say that well you
know what
some people in this country are really
really stupid
um and so there may be people who are
dumb enough to read that b
article and not understand that it's
satire
so maybe this is a reflection of
america's stupidity not usa today's
but i can't let them off the hook that
easily i think it's a combination of
both factors because
first of all anyone who's dumb enough to
believe that a court
overturned a woman's death isn't going
to have the wherewithal to then go
and research the claim right like a
person that dumb isn't going to go hmm
let me cross-check this claim and see if
it's reported in any reputable sources
no that's just they're just going to
read it go
uh okay
and then stuff with another cheeto into
their mouth and keep scrolling
that's that's what's going to happen so
unfortunately usa today
uh still must be blamed for the
stupidity number three the new york post
headline
nearly 70 percent of americans say
they're done with coffee shops after
becoming
at-home baristas it says half americans
have become
coristas during 2020 quarristas like
quarantine baristas
um okay first of all just
we gotta stop right there if you have
ever called yourself a quarrista
that is an automatic eviction from the
human race i'm not saying you should be
executed
i'm not not saying that mainly i'm just
saying you can't be a human anymore we
don't want you in
the human you can pick another species
you know maybe see if the llamas will
take you i don't know
anyway a survey of 2 000 coffee drinkers
revealed 49
of respondents have become at home
baristas during quarantine using their
time
inside to develop their coffee making
skills two-thirds of those have so much
faith in their nude-found talent they
plan to continue using their barista
knowledge to make coffee
in their own kitchen even once the
pandemic is over okay listen
making coffee at home we used to just
call that
making coffee at home you're not an
at-home barista now that you turn the
coffee pot on
that's not am i an at-home mechanical
engineer because i changed the batteries
in my remote
no come on number four the daily wire uh
let's see
dally wire says actor jason isaacs the
man who previously called ivanka trump a
brainless barbie
um said that uh non-mask wearer should
be hanging in the streets or in prison
speaking of the british daytime chats
speaking on the british daytime chat
show lorraine uh isaac said that he is
actually less annoyed by non-mask
wearers
than he is by people who don't wear them
properly adding that non-mask wearer
should be imprisoned or executed
wow you know maybe i can't judge him for
threatening to have people executed for
superfluous reasons
um i do that like 14 times a show
i just did it a second ago actually but
it's different when i do it
you know that that's my thing right
that's my being in
being an enraged lunatic is my whole
deal and everyone
knows that if something is your whole
deal then it's okay
that's that's the rule everyone knows
that that's that's the old excuse and
it's a good one i think
you know if you're just like a jerk to
everybody all the time
then whenever anyone accuses you of
being a jerk
someone else can go oh he's just being
himself
as if the fact that you're horrible a
lot makes it okay
if you're only horrible sometimes it's
not but if you're if you're that way all
the time you know you're consistent
about it then it's okay
anyway this is obviously overblown and
if we're gonna be doling out
harsh mask-related penalties um i'd
rather dull them out in the other
direction like i took my kids to the
beach
uh a couple days over the weekend i took
my kids to the beach all four kids by
myself to the beach by the way um
kids seven and younger uh i i took i
don't i don't know why i decided to do
this but
we had to get him out of the house
because my wife was getting getting the
house ready to sell
staging and everything and um
anyway i took the kids to the beach but
i i couldn't help but notice even though
i'm i'm distracted by trying to keep
track of all
all the kids i can still take the time
to be annoyed and angry by things
that it's my special skill and the
people on the beach or near the beach
like walking on the boardwalk
wearing masks okay um that if there's
gonna be penalties
if i was in charge the penalty would be
for that because you look ridiculous
and there's absolutely no reason to do
that you're at the beach
okay you really rather than breathing in
that nice fresh ocean air you're gonna
breathe in your own fumes you really
think that's healthier for you
really number five finally here's an
article that escaped my attention a year
ago
um but i just saw it now because making
the rounds again online
telling us of a certain group that i'm
guessing probably with covet has been on
hiatus
so if you're looking to join the group
you'll probably have to wait but
these people exist and they're out there
um it is uh here's what it says from the
inquirer.com it says
twice a month half a dozen men gather in
plymouth meeting
in a plymouth meeting to help each other
work through past traumas
their chosen method of healing cuddles
it may seem odd but members of the men's
therapeutic
cuddle group say the practice has helped
them cope with everything from childhood
sexual abuse to the loss of family
members when they were young
the two-year-old group draws men from
various backgrounds a 37 year old mormon
57 year old married father of three a 62
year old retiree
there's a range of sexual orientations
at a time when traditional ideas of
manhood are facing scrutiny
in such terms as toxic masculinity or
becoming widely known
uh the group aims to provide new ways
for men to express themselves
unlike professional cuddling services
which is a thing professional cuddling
services
the group charges no fees that's good
and members are not required to
undergo training
can you get a degree in cuddling i bet
you can i bet you can
although the meetups are not open to the
public the group held a demonstration
for the enquirer
at the beginning of the session everyone
agreed not to engage in sexual touch
and to ask for consent before each
action they gathered in a huddle and
breathed meditatively the cuddling
started with men
pairing up to do the motorcycle hold
this sounds horrifying already uh in
what in which one man sits with his back
against another man's chest as if they
were riding together on a motorcycle
some massage their paren their their
partner's
shoulders or or hands while others
stroked the other person's beard
many clothes stroke the other person's
beard
many close their eyes as the room fell
into silence after 15 minutes they
switched to a new partner
for the second half of the session the
men cuddled as one large group
in what they call a puppy pile
men lay with their heads in each other's
laps chatted and joked
oh my god in heaven god help us
god help us all and you know you know
you know all these dudes use emojis okay
so i
you know i'm right about this i i don't
know do i need to spell out the issues
here do i need to
what you find here actually illustrated
in in very disturbing and graphic detail
um is this fundamental misunderstanding
on the left
about masculinity and femininity and
they think oh well you know
we just have to tear down the artifice
of masculinity we have to
the artificial construct of masculinity
we have to tear down um because that's
the only reason
that dudes don't cuddle they really want
to
deep down but they don't because they're
worried that society will frown on
you know frown upon it no no see that's
not it yes
society will frown upon it and should
but that's not the point
society could give the puppy pile filled
with dudes a big thumbs up
and i still would decline because the
whole reason we don't associate men with
cuddling
isn't that men don't cuddle because we
don't associate them with it
it's that we it's that we we don't
associate them with it
because they don't do it okay for the
most part there is something deeply
ingrained
naturally ingrained in our net in our
masculine nature that makes us far less
touchy-feely than women
there are exceptions sometimes those
exceptions take horrific form like this
but
you're never going to build a society of
cuddling men because most men
don't have that in them thank god so we
will continue to confine ourselves
to handshakes fist bumps
um the off awkward sort of half
handshake half hug thing
or my specialty is the series of aborted
greetings
that you that you get when you know
there's two guys that don't know how the
other likes to greet
and so you get the kind of going in for
the handshakes the
kind of handshake and then it looks like
they're going for a hug and then you
back up and then it's just kind of
and you're you know it's like you're a
video game sort of like
freezing um that's my move
my move in other words is to make
everyone feel a lot less comfortable
than they did before i entered the room
but
they're still a lot more comfortable
than they would be if i walked into the
room
and asked who's up for a good cuddle uh
i i think
that would make it far less
comfortable i think all right we're
gonna get to our daily cancellation in
just a second um but first
you know we've been telling you about
helix sleep when you don't get
a good night's rest i think you you you
know it uh you you know it the next day
you can feel it
you're feeling sore you're feeling
you're just not with it um
the the effects of not having a good
night's sleep and a lot of people in
america don't get good night's sleep
and the health effects are um are
it's a long list of health effects and
that's why you need helix sleep helix
sleep has
a quiz that takes just two minutes to
complete matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you
if you like a mattress that's really
soft or firm if you sleep on your side
your back your stomach or you sleep
really hot with helix there's a specific
mattress for each and everybody's unique
taste
you don't need to take their word for it
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress of 2019 and 2020 by gq
and wired magazine there's a reason for
that
go to helixsleep.com take their two
minute quiz they'll match you to a
customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life i've done this myself
i can confirm i've taken the quiz didn't
take very long and they sent me a
mattress that
well it's it felt like it was
tailor-made for me because
it was um right now helix is offering up
to 200
off and free pillows with all mattress
orders for our listeners at helix sleep
dot com slash walls that's helix sleep
dot com slash walsh for up to
200 off your mattress order so go there
now
and one other note um you know talking
about the debate if you if you liked our
debate coverage last night you should
join daily wire now as an insider or
all-access member
and get 20 off with code debate so
uh you can watch all of our upcoming
debate coverage live at dailywire.com
apple tv roku app
there are going to be more debates for
some reason and uh
and so we're going to be here for that
members also get our articles ad free
you get access to all the live
broadcasts you get the all access
membership you get everything
so but also if you want to watch the
next debate with us get 20
off your daily wire membership at the
same time you use code debate
when you go to dailywire.com and sign up
today all right let's get to our daily
cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we're
canceling the atlantic for the latest
and perhaps most pitiful
media generated trump scandal one that
will likely have the same impact on the
president's
pres you know political fortunes as the
stunning revelation that
he doesn't pay more income tax than he
owes this time it's the atlantic's mckay
coppins claiming that
trump mocks his christian supporters
behind their backs and speaks with quote
cynicism and contempt about religion
and this would be mostly irrelevant even
if it was true as i'll explain in a
minute but
the specific examples provided in the
article don't live up to the headline's
hype as usual
we are first regaled with a tale of
trump mocking millionaire prosperity
preacher creflo dollar
after the pastor tried to raise 60
million dollars for a private jet
trump allegedly called it a scam said
that dollar
is full of crap and then added
they're all hustlers now we aren't told
who the all is in that context but it
seems safe to conclude that he was
referring to the sorts of preachers who
fly around on private jets
assuming that you know disgraced and
currently imprisoned
michael cohen the source of this
anecdote can be trusted here which is a
dubious assumption to say the least
there's nothing objectional
objectionable about any of this
creflo dollar is indeed a hustler who is
indeed full of crap
i think i can speak for a great many
christians in america
except those credulous saps who actually
donated to the private jet fundraiser
and say that we agree with trump's
assessment
though some of us would maybe phrase it
in not exactly the same
way i mean i would put it the same way
but a lot of christians wouldn't
another bombshell follows a quoting from
the atlantic here
the former campaign advisor recalled
showing his boss a youtube video of the
israeli
uh televangelist benny hinn performing
faith healings while trump laughed at
the spectacle and muttered
man that's some racket on another
occasion the advisor told me
trump expressed awe at joel osteen's
media empire particularly the viewership
of his televised sermons
now our source in this case is an
ex-white house official
who is speaking on the condition of
anonymity uh the track record of of this
ex white house official group has of
course been been less than admirable
but even again taking the supposed
regulation recollections at face value
there is little here that the average
conservative christian would disagree
with
televised faith healing is a racket and
also a ridiculous spectacle to behold
now personally i find myself more
recoiling and revulsion than laughing
when i see frauds like benny hinn in
action but you know laughter is probably
a better
well certainly emotionally healthier
reaction now things do get a little bit
edgier with the next alleged revelation
again this is from the atlantic it says
in cohen's recent memoir disloyal he
recounts trump returning from his 2011
meeting with pastors who laid hands on
him
and sneering can you believe that bull
bull crap
but if trump found their rituals
ridiculous he followed their
money-making ventures closely
he was completely he was completely
familiar with his business dealings with
the business dealings of the leadership
in many prosperity gospel churches the
advisor told me
now okay that is probably not how most
christians would
respond in a similar situation and it
may not be how trump responded given
that we're getting this again from an
incarcerated felon but not all
christians are comfortable with having
hands ritualistically laid on them in
prayer
count me among that group in fact um i
generally prefer not to have strangers
touch me at all for any reason
your prayers are just as powerful
without physical contact thank you you
don't need to put your hands on me
now later on in the article it's claimed
that trump also made some relatively
tame
jokes about mormons jewish people other
faith groups
you know we're never given any examples
of him specifically mocking his
christian supporters as the headline
declared
but none of this stuff matters anyway
the media has never been able to
understand
trump's support among faithful
christians and their lack of
understanding has rendered useless their
attempts at chipping away at it
now there may be a small minority of
christians
who you know for some reason actually
believe that trump is a deeply spiritual
man
but most would not be surprised to hear
aj delgado in the atlantic
um describing him as quote not a
religious guy
you know that's not a problem because
christians are not turning to trump for
spiritual leadership
or exegetical enlightenment they
probably would not want him to lead
their bible studies or take over the
pastoral duties at their church
the point has always been policy trump
has not advanced any policies that
assault religious liberty or undermine
the sanctity of life
on the contrary his administration has
fought for policies that protect
both religious liberty and the sanctity
of life it's that simple
his personal religious views are
irrelevant now contrast that with a man
like joe biden
who describes himself as devout and yet
supports the butchery of unborn children
and believes that nuns should be legally
forced to purchase contraception
why don't conservative christians line
up behind biden well he's an old white
guy too so writing us off as racist or
bigoted
won't be sufficient in this case we
don't like biden
because we find his policies to be
morally appalling
and in direct contradiction to christian
teaching whatever he personally believes
however often he prays however however
much he goes to church
none of that mitigates the many terrible
things
he wishes to do with the power of the
presidency
should it be granted to him that's what
all this comes down to
it's not so hard to understand
and for that the atlantic is canceled
and everyone in media who doesn't
understand this basic concept is
cancelled
and i am canceled too just for the rest
of the week uh actually until tuesday
because i'm taking off a few days
uh so that's gonna do it for me for the
week i'll see you guys back here on
tuesday
have a great week godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching
and the moon has turned to blood but on
the andrew clavin show that's where the
fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clinton